SPEAKER: Cloud SQL Insights
is a simple open tool
that helps developers quickly
understand and resolve
database performance
issues on Cloud SQL.
It provides developers
with a single interface
for self-service
application-centric monitoring
and diagnosis of database
performance issues.
To access Insights, I
can click Query Insights
in the left navigation.
I'm going to walk
you through how
to use Insights to identify and
diagnose a database performance
problem in an application.
In this scenario, I'm
an application developer
on a team that developed a
ride-sharing application.
We've gotten a report
from some of our users
that the application
is running slowly.
Let's look at how
I can use Insights
to investigate and find
the cause of the problem.
Looking at the top-level
query insights dashboard,
I'll start with
the database load
all queries graph, which
can help me visually
identify performance problems
or spikes in database load.
The database load graph
confirms that there's
a problem that started
happening around 12 o'clock.
The colors in the
graph help me see
that there's an increase in
CPU and an even larger increase
in lock weight.
Now I need to find
out which query
is causing the problem, what the
root cause of the problem is,
and where in my application
code the problem lies.
To try to identify which
query is causing the problem,
I'll start with
the queries table.
The queries table contains
normalized queries
for the time frame selected.
The queries in the table are
sorted by total execution time
by default, but I can also
filter it by other criteria,
like CPU time, I/O
weight, or lock weight.
The first query in
the table certainly
stands out, as its total
execution time is much larger
than the rest of the entries.
Like many modern
applications, this application
consists of several
different services
and I want to know which one
is causing the performance
problem.
Traditional
monitoring tools only
provide a query-centric
view of performance.
With Insights, I can toggle
from the queries table
to the tags table to
see a list of queries
tagged by business logic, giving
me an application-centric view.
The tags table is
especially helpful to me
as a developer, since
this application was built
using Django's ORM
rather than by writing
the SQL queries myself.
Insights uses SQL commenter,
an open source library
which provides instrumentation
and wrappers to augment SQL
from frameworks in ORMs.
If your application is using
one of the supported ORMs,
the queries are automatically
tagged with little to no change
to your application code.
So you're more easily able
to identify query load
and pinpoint where the problem
may lie in your application,
since you can see information
like actions, controllers,
and routes.
The first tag query for the
payment charge controller
looks like it's the problem.
Now that I've identified that
this is likely the slow query,
I want to find
out why it's slow.
I'm going to click through to
see more details for this tag
query.
Insights include sample
executed query plans, which
I can use to understand
why the query is slow.
Query plans can be complex
and difficult to understand,
but Insights provides
visual query plans
that can help me easily
detect which part of the query
is slow.
Each part of the query shows
the latency, rows returned,
and the costs for
that operation.
In this query, an
update is happening.
The modified table looks
to be contributing the most
to the latency because
of locking contention.
Now that we've identified
the slow query and the cause,
let's confirm the
source of the problem.
Insights provides in
context visualization
of end-to-end tracing to help me
find which application code is
causing the problem.
In addition to being able to
see the controller and route,
it can also help me understand
if a particular host or user is
the source of a problem.
While I'm viewing the
trace visualization
from within Insights
in this example,
Insights complements your
existing APM and observability
tools.
Insights provides database
metrics and traces
through the Open
Standard, OpenTelemetry,
and Cloud monitoring
and Cloud trace APIs.
This makes it easy to
do end-to-end tracing
in your existing tools.
In this video,
we've looked at ways
you can use Cloud SQL insights
to help with diagnosing
and troubleshooting
application performance issues
all from a single intuitive UI.
In the description
below the video,
you'll find links to a blog
post introducing insights
and the documentation for Cloud
SQL insights and SQL commenter.
Or you can click on the Codelab
to try it out for yourself.